hello and welcome to maths implied in
this video we will learn about an
awesome method to remember the steps and
enzymes of glycolysis in a simplified
way I found biochemistry extremely
difficult to memorize when I was in
college every pathway that I used to
study I used to spend hours on an end to
remember that and all of that was gone
in a week eventually you get to know
about the awesome technique of using
mnemonics as a memory aid and I
discovered some mnemonics to help me
remember this complex pathway of
glycolysis now obviously before
beginning I hope all of you have seen
the videos of glycolysis on our channel
well if you haven't made sure to do that
so you have a better understanding of
this topic the link to the videos about
glycolysis and other topics of
carbohydrate metabolism are in the
description below so glycolysis is the
initial pathway of metabolism of
carbohydrates through the pathway of
glycolysis glucose which is a six carbon
compound is broken down into two
molecules of pyruvate which is a three
carbon compound this is why this is
known as a lysis or break down since
glucose is being broken down into
smaller fragments known as pyruvate now
this break down involves ten steps and
all these steps use enzymes that make
the reactions possible how to remember
glycolysis in a better way you first
need to remember all the intermediate
products that are formed in the pathway
of glycolysis and then we will try to
memorize about the various enzymes that
are involved in the pathway at different
steps so first let's memorize all the
intermediate molecules of glycolysis
with a simple mnemonic and to memorize
this mnemonic first you will listen to
one of the most bizarre stories you have
ever heard and I guess that is probably
a good thing as that makes sure you
won't forget it for a lifetime so listen
there are two types of voice one are
good guys and the other are gross guys
the gross guys they favor big butts and
the good ones they prefer pretty girls
in pink pajamas okay now you may ask
what does all of this hazard
with a breakdown of glucose well this
story actually brings us to our first
mnemonic
gross guys favor big putts but good boys
prefer pretty girls in pink pajamas this
mnemonic is based on the following
substances the G in gross stands for
glucose which is the first molecule used
in glycolysis again we have one more G
that stands for glucose 6-phosphate
which is a next molecule in this pathway
the F in the word favor stands for
fructose 6-phosphate
in the next reaction another phosphate
molecule gets attached to fructose
6-phosphate to make it of fructose 1 6
bisphosphate since it is a bisphosphate
now the word for it in the mnemonic
starts with B that is big butts
next to words we have in the mnemonic
our good boys the G in good stands for
closer aldehyde 3 phosphate which is
produced when fructose 1 6 bisphosphate
is split into two molecules one is
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate and the
second one is dihydroxyacetone phosphate
only the glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate can
move forward with the pathway of
glycolysis and not the dihydroxyacetone
phosphate this is why only
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate is included
in the mnemonic the next word is boys
which stands for bisphosphoglycerate
more particularly 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate so the last line in
the mnemonic was good boys prefer pretty
girls in pink pajamas and here you can
see the next few molecules that come in
the pathway of glycolysis the P in
prefer stands for 3 phosphoglycerate
which is a product formed when we remove
one phosphate from 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate the next P in pretty
stands for 2-phosphoglycerate
the product formed as a result of
transfer of one phosphate rope from the
third position to the second position
the P in pink stands for
phosphoenolpyruvate and the P in pyjamas
stands for pyruvate which is a last
molecule generated in the pathway of
glycolysis so this was a memory trick to
remember all the intermediate molecules
that form in the pathway of glycolysis
now you also need to remember all the
enzymes that are involved in these
reactions and trust me when I was back
in college I have found it extremely
hard to remember the enzymes of
glycolysis and Krebs cycle until I found
some good mnemonics of course and for
this first listen to this small stupid
story about a girl named Helen
so this is Helen and she's a 15 year old
cute little girl living in her home just
in front of Helens home our training
grounds for players where they do their
exercises and play and all that now
Helen used to sit along the training
grounds and paint pictures all day long
and she used to pray that people enjoyed
her paintings and this brings us to our
pneumonic that will help us to remember
all the enzymes of glycolysis Helen
paints pictures along the training
grounds praying people enjoy paintings
so we have Helen who paints pictures
along the training grounds and she used
to pray that people enjoyed her
paintings now in this mnemonic the H
stands for hexokinase
which is the first enzyme involved in
glycolysis which converts glucose into
glucose 6-phosphate P stands for
phosphoglucose isomerase the enzyme
which converts glucose 6-phosphate to
fructose 6-phosphate
the next letter we have in this mnemonic
is again a P and the enzyme here is
phosphofructokinase one which converted
fructose 6-phosphate to fructose 1 6
bisphosphate next we have aldolase from
the letter A this enzyme breaks down
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate into
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate the next
enzyme is again an isomerase that
catalyzes the isomerization of
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate to
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and
vice-versa now since this isomerase is
acting on three carbon compounds the
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and
dihydroxyacetone phosphate the complete
name for the enzyme is triose phosphate
isomerase therefore the letter T the
next word we have in our mnemonic is
ground which starts with G the G here
stands for our next enzyme in glycolysis
which is glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
dehydrogenase this enzyme converts
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate to 1 3
bisphosphoglycerate
next letter we have in the mnemonic is a
B which stands for phosphoglycerate
kinase this kinase catalyzed the
conversion of 1 3 bisphosphoglycerate to
3 phosphoglycerate next we have a P
again and this stands for
phosphoglycerate mutase the enzyme which
converted 3 phosphoglycerate to
2-phosphoglycerate the world enjoy in
the mnemonic stands for our next enzyme
in o lace inner lace converts to
phosphoglycerate 2 phosphoenolpyruvate
the last word in the mnemonic is again a
P which stands for pyruvate kinase this
is the enzyme use in the last step of
glycolysis in the conversion of
phosphoenolpyruvate
to pyruvate now all these mnemonics are
useful only when you have a thorough
understanding of the topic of glycolysis
and the rest of carbohydrate metabolism
make sure to watch these videos on
glycolysis kreb cycle and electron
transport chain to have a complete
understanding of the topics you can get
the flashcards from this video as well
as the lecture handouts from all our
other videos by joining a community at
patreon.com or clicking the join button
below thank you so much for watching see
you in the next video